we think the cyber threat is increasing
almost exponentially
ransomware is becoming an increasingly
severe and pervasive problem
we all have a role to play in keeping
our nation safe
no organization is immune we always
thought we were small potatoes who would
pick
a single library out of the world
to attack and and that just goes to show
that it could happen to anybody
ransomware is a practice hackers use to
lock up computer systems and demand a
payment from victims for their release
data on ransomware attacks varies widely
and estimates are difficult to make
because many attacks are never made
public or reported to law enforcement
but security officials agree the problem
is rapidly getting worse
these attacks are increasing in
frequency victim losses are skyrocketing
and hackers are shifting their targets
away from data rich companies to
providers of key public needs
such as hospitals transportation and
food
what's causing the current acceleration
in frequency and scope of these attacks
there are at least four main factors
first
victims continue to make cyber security
mistakes like clicking on phishing links
or failing to keep company software
updated these criminal groups are still
finding it too easy
to exploit weak cyber security or
failure to execute cyber security best
practices
a ransomware attack on colonial pipeline
forced the 5500 mile pipeline to shut
down for six days
spurring a run on gasoline along parts
of the east coast
investigators believe hackers were able
to break into the company's computer
systems by logging into an out-of-use
vpn profile
that lacked two-factor authentication
the public library in brownsburg indiana
found themselves in a similar situation
in 2017.
we believe the hackers came in through
our card catalog and which is where you
look for books
it's open to the public so it's an open
venue
the attack locked robinson and her staff
out of email cardholder information
and their entire library catalog of over
one hundred thousand items
the library paid half of a bitcoin
approximately thirteen hundred dollars
at the time
to regain access second
ransomware attacks have become very
lucrative for hackers
in the past several weeks alone jbs
whose meat plants were temporarily
knocked offline by cyber criminals
and colonial pipeline have paid many
millions of dollars
to get their systems back up and running
considering the consequences of
potentially not bringing the pipeline
back on as quickly as i possibly could
i chose the option to make the ransom
payment both the colonial pipeline and
jbs ransom payments were made using
cryptocurrency
which has a reputation for being hard to
track but an announcement by the justice
department that they'd recovered about
2.3 million of colonial's initial ransom
demonstrates investigators growing
technical ability in some cases to
disrupt the financial infrastructure
that has enabled these ransomware gangs
to demand large sums
the sophisticated use of technology to
hold businesses
and even whole cities hostage for profit
is decidedly a 21st century
challenge but the old adage follow the
money
still applies cryptocurrency isn't the
only reason ransomware attacks have
become more lucrative
some hackers are now utilizing double
extortion tactics in which they steal
sensitive data from their victims before
encrypting it
and then threaten to publish that
information if victims refuse to pay
third hacking groups have reinvented the
process through which criminal networks
extort victims
ransomware has a service as a practice
in which hacking networks can sell or
lease the ransomware software to other
criminal groups to carry out attacks
those affiliate groups then share the
proceeds with the hackers who developed
it
dark side the criminal group linked to
the colonial pipeline hack works in this
way
and finally according to u.s officials
and cyber security researchers
the majority of these hacks are coming
from russia and eastern europe
where security experts say the line
between criminal hacking groups
and state-backed cyber operations can be
murky as governments often tolerate
criminal activity
as long as it is targeted overseas and
sometimes even recruit hackers from
those groups to carry out their own
objectives
following a highly anticipated summit
between president biden and vladimir
putin in geneva
the russian leader said he agreed to
start consultations on cyber security
and denied that moscow was involved in
any cyber attacks at a separate news
conference
president biden said he presented mr
putin with a list of critical
infrastructure
that he said should be off limits
responsible countries need to take
action against criminals
who conduct ransomware activities on
their territory
so we agreed to tax experts
in both our both our countries to work
on specific understandings
about what's off limits and to follow up
on specific
cases that originate in other countries
in either our countries so what can
individuals and companies do now to
better protect themselves
goldstein said sisa is focused on
helping ensure that organizations
understand basic steps that they need to
adopt to protect themselves like running
up-to-date software
and using multi-factor authentication he
hopes the intrusions at colonial
pipeline and jbs serve as a wake-up call
for organizations across
the country the first barrier to
increasing adoption of cyber security
best practices
is is ensuring awareness among business
management and business leaders
to make sure that when companies are
deciding where to invest
and which risks to invest in driving
down cyber security and the risk of
ransomware attacks
is seen as a top priority risk robinson
said that after they recovered from the
ransomware attack on the library they
implemented many security changes to
prevent future attacks
like reworking their server backup
system we made sure that our catalog
was on a firewall we have a product
called silence that's running that's
watching for not just known viruses
but unusual activity following the
ransomware attack on colonial pipeline
president biden said ransomware was a
growing problem in need of a global
response
as part of that response tsa released
security directives requiring pipeline
operators to provide notification when
they are targets or victims of cyber
attacks
to appoint a cyber security coordinator
and to review their current activities
and some lawmakers and former government
officials say that the federal
government should now expand mandatory
cyber security requirements
across critical infrastructure sectors
additionally some lawmakers have said
they may be open to considering
legislation that could make ransom
payments illegal in some cases
or require companies to disclose when
they make a ransom payment to hackers
fbi officials said the techniques they
use to recover some of colonial's funds
can be used in future cases
including when hackers attempt to
transfer cryptocurrency through
unfriendly overseas jurisdictions
we are looking at this as a as a whole
of solutions effort in which we need to
focus
on the the groups themselves their
infrastructures
and then shoring up defenses across
victim companies and by focusing deeply
on each of those areas
we'll be able to drive down this risk
over time